hey everybody what is going on I'm back
talking about a pair of nikor lenses
that I've tried on the Nikon zfc you
probably saw some images in that review
but I want to talk a little bit more in
depth on them we've got the Nikkor z105
F 2.8 s line lens here on the Nikon z72
and of course the uh 50 millimeter of
2.8 nikor micro lens and also for
comparison for fun I do have an AIS
version of the 105. so with that
let's talk about these lenses
thank you
so before we kick things off I do want
to thank Nikon Singapore for providing
the Nikon z7 II for loan the 105 F 2.8 s
line micro lens and the 50 F 2.8 micro
lens this 105 AIS version here is mine
uh just have it here for more of show
because the optical quality is different
core Z to the AIS there's a big
difference so anyway let's talk about
these lenses the 105 F 2.8 s line lens
is the flagship out of the tube this is
the big boy it's got VR in it arnio Nano
Crystal Coatings and fluorine Coatings
it is the S line so you can have the
customizable ring on the back that LED
display the customizable function button
of course you have your autofocus and
manual focus switch on this and your
full to 0.5 to 0.29 meters in terms of
your focal range this is part and parcel
with the macro lenses because if you're
close up on a subject you don't want the
lens to go hunting quite a bit just have
an area where it can focus in and you
know Focus faster
um
in terms of performance on this
it's fantastic guys I mean what do you
expect from a Nikon these days I gotta
say most of their Z Mountain lenses just
knock it out of the park and this one
just blew my mind the sharpness the fall
off the colors uh I mean I've tried the
G lens before and I tried this AIS lens
and they're fantastic lenses right
they're great this is just
on another level altogether I mean
what is there to say you're going to see
in some of the images in a bit how sharp
this lens is
I'll talk about performance in a bit
because there are some things that I
came across on the z7 II but
in terms of optical quality
phenomenal now let's talk about the 50 F
2.8 this lens is not an s-line lens so
you're not going to get all the bells
and whistles as you're going to get on
the 105. you're not going to get that
arnio or Nano Crystal coating to it
you're still going to get the fluorine
coating there is no customizable ring on
the back of this no LED display or you
know function button on this you just
have your autofocus and manual focus
switch full to 0.3 to 1 0.16 meters in
terms of focal range on that so you know
if you want to nail your focus in closer
of course you use that it does sort of
have the front element that protrudes
out a little bit when it's close
focusing so that is something to keep in
mind but this is a great little walk
around lens at a 50 F 2.8 nice focal
length you can use it day in day as a
lens but you get that one to one macro
ratio the same as this 105 F 2.8 it is a
one to one macro lens which is nice
because some macro lenses are not
one-to-one out there okay they can uh
vary and so that's off to Nikon for
making this a true one-to-one macro lens
now in terms of Optics this is fantastic
fantastic even though it is not getting
that Nano and arnio Crystal coating to
it so as the floor encoding I didn't
really notice much of a difference it is
bitingly sharp great colors out of it I
didn't notice any flaring in my testing
out there it is just a fantastic lens in
that regard and I found it to be a very
compact lightweight lens to carry around
when I put on the Nikon zfc it felt
great when I put on the z7 II it's easy
and lightweight in the bag versus the
105 which does have some heft to it so
if you're looking for an up just a great
day-to-day lens
and you want macro capabilities when you
need them
try out the 50 I think you'll be very
impressed with it now in terms of
performance this is where it was really
interesting for me because
with the 105 F 2.8 and autofocus mode
and I tried various different modes with
this right I found my focusing was a bit
off and I don't know if it's the camera
or the lens because these are demo units
and sometimes this happens but I found
that my hit rate wasn't really great
with the 105 all the time I had to take
multiple shots to really nail where I
wanted to be even when I did like
pinpoint focusing on this you know I
never felt a hundred percent that I
could just take one shot and nail it I
always thought I had to take two or
three shots because either there was
some camera shake and that's odd because
you've got the stabilization inside the
body and of course VR in the lens
or what I don't know what it was but I
wasn't really nailing it as good as I
wanted to nail but when you hit the shot
when you get it in focus wow now a lot
of people out there will be saying Bobby
just manual focus it that's pretty much
what we do with macro lenses and I agree
a lot of the times I would manual focus
it because the manual focusing system in
the Z system is fantastic it works great
I use it nailed Focus no issues at all
but I'm just talking in terms of
autofocus now with the 50 of 2.8
my hit rate was much higher it was so
much easier and yes you can say well
it's a 50 versus a 105 you know there is
a difference and I'm like
when I'm really close up on a subject
I'm still getting that that area I want
to get in Focus much easier on the 50
than I was getting on the 105. again it
could be user error it just could be
because these are demo lenses but I will
tell you on both of these lenses in
terms of Optics you will be hard-pressed
to see a difference between these two
lenses it's really going to be do you
want a 105 or do you want a 50
millimeter because on Lightroom and
you're going to see some sample images
in just a bit
they are beautiful images wide open stop
down I'm getting some spectacular images
out of these lenses so with that I'm
going to show you a quick Montage of the
shots I've taken at the gay culture
Studios of these Collectibles we've got
there
with the 105 F 2.8 the 50 F 2.8 and then
I also went to the flower Dome and
Gardens by the bay to shoot some flowers
because you got to shoot flowers when
you do macro right so that check out
these uh images and I'll be back with
you with my final thoughts
[Music]
thank you
jizz there the 105 and the 50 F 2.8 are
fantastic performing lenses I mean the
colors the fall off the bokeh the
sharpness the sharpness the amount of
detail is it's beautiful and you know
I've been getting into macro photography
a little bit more as of later because
you know we're all facing these
situations where sometimes we have to be
at home for a couple weeks or a few days
or whatever the case may be and it's
just sort of a way for me to uh you know
get that Creative Juice going you know
with photography and I think these
lenses are fantastic for that and yes
compared to let's say in AIS a g or a d
lens for the 105 for that matter I mean
the Z Mount is a higher resolving lens
especially with the 50 as well they're
designed for a mirrorless camera system
that can go up Beyond 50 megapixels and
you know with the arneo Nano Crystal
Coatings the flooring Coatings and the
lens design you're getting the best out
of Nikon right now and honestly I mean
non-biased perspective I think they make
some of the best mirrorless lenses on
the market right now I do I haven't come
across a Nikkor lens with a z-mount that
I have really disliked I mean some of
the kit lenses may be so but when you
come into these you know these primes or
these s-line lenses huh I mean it
doesn't get much better than this it
really does I mean they get large in
terms of size and weight but performance
is there between the two honestly I
think if I was to choose one
I mean it depends if you're doing if
you're a portraiture uh photographer but
you also want to do macro then I would
definitely go for the 105 because this
is a great portrait lens but if you want
a daily lens to walk around with do some
street photography but you also want
macro capabilities this 50 is a hard
lens to beat the price point is good
it's lightweight it fits great on the
z72 and the zfc and Z50 or any other
Nikon cameras out there and
yeah I really enjoyed shooting with the
50 far more than I thought I was going
to that was probably the biggest
surprise for me out of these two lenses
is how much I enjoyed the 50. there is a
significant difference I think Nikon has
designed these lenses to be used on
higher megapixel uh mirrorless systems
versus the g the D and the AIS which was
meant to be used on film and on DSLR
camera systems and up to a certain you
know resolving power so these two lenses
here would be Staples for any macro
photographer my personal opinion and I
just highly recommend them they're
absolutely beautiful when it comes to
image quality the sharpness the
rendering
wow so with that those are my thoughts
on the lenses let me know your thoughts
in the comment section below do you
agree with me is there anything else I
should be looking out for did I make a
mistake in terms of using the 105 I
would love to hear from you uh but
follow us on Facebook subscribe to us on
YouTube like this video it helps us out
a lot especially the algorithm lately on
YouTube so that stay safe take care I'll
chat to you in the next one bye
[Music]
thank you